a man is under arrest for selling bogus
covid19 treatments thanks for staying
with us here at 6 30 i'm denise feltes
and i'm brian loftis now those
treatments the i-team learning about a
local man accused of selling a fake
coveted treatment made with a machine
described as the one he used to clean
pools
officers arresting 53 year old elias
beltran after getting a tip they say he
was selling a so-called covid cure with
chlorine dioxide high amounts of the
chemical are used in bleach a local
doctor says just trust the science
it really is just about making sure that
you are safe and at this point the
safest thing for you to do is to get
vaccinated and to go with the thing that
we know that is proven
according to his arrest report a woman
had recently contacted beltran about her
six-year-old son who was diagnosed with
cova 19. now police say beltran offered
to sell her his machine for several
hundreds of dollars investigators add he
has no license to practice medicine in
nevada